[Music]  females await welcome then I'll speak  from California it's gonna be alright  just the corner the one that looks the  loneliest and speaking short sentences  hello my name is n it's short for Henry  I'm Sam  tell that this Punk do more ultimate  what do people do when an ordinary day  we do what we want  have you no restrictions  that was the future I slept at his house  and met his mom sorry look it's my first  time at this it's taking longer than I  expected and we engage in incomplete  sexual activity  [Music]  she's not not I bet they participate in  some bizarre sex rituals no how do you  have that I just don't see it happening  you have less than 24 hours to rectify  the situation you're in extreme danger  we have to leave now  Sam each hope will need backup  [Music]  we may have caught this planet up  royally but at least went a lie we like  to eat we like to dance to fall in love  and we try and fix what our parents  screwed up  are you locked with me  you